he's Lane Kiffin was with Alabama no
longer now the head coach at Florida
Atlantic and joins us now coach how are
you this morning great Dan thanks for
having me where are you today I am in
Boca at Florida Atlantic I take me back
a couple of weeks ago when you took this
job why Florida Atlantic well it was
about the people so going through these
process the floors you you know you go
through the interview process and sit
down and you know there's usually maybe
four three four five six seven people in
there you know from the University and a
lot of times you go in these and you
kind of have split rooms you know where
you feel like half of them are really
about football and really understand the
things it takes to win and and then
maybe hassle mark or maybe ask them
really like you but half of them kind of
like someone else you know another
candidate I felt in this situation there
were five people in the room the
president athletic director and three
other powerful people at the University
and it was it was very obvious to me
coming out of that room that they had a
plan a specific plan of making Florida
Atlantic a championship program and a
specific plan of coming to get me
to be part of that and so I just left
the room with a great feeling about it
and obviously it's a great location when
it comes for recruiting as you look at
all the Florida schools really every one
of them you know whether it's UCF USF
this year obviously Florida Florida
State Miami every school every school
has had a run of some really good teams
at times and that's because of the great
high school coaches and the great
players in the state of Florida so it
all just came together and was um you
know stage in my career where I wasn't
just looking to be a head coach no
matter what and just taking a job no
matter what it had to be a place that I
felt was committed to winning and that
we could go and really win because um
you know winning is really fun just like
it's been for these last 26 games you go
back and you talk to Nick
what was the arrangement you guys had
for the remainder of the season when I
came back I had the press conference
down here and came back that next day
and asked coach what he wanted to do
obviously he's dead coach and the
decision he said that he wanted me to to
stay on in coach and you know try to
manage manage both jobs we laid out a
plan that was really basically in the in
the kind of downtime you know in the
bowl preparation you know that would be
FAU time whether that was calling
recruits whether that was watching
recruits on film watching your current
roster see where there's a lot of stuff
obviously when you take a head job that
normally you're there and you're there
all day long every day and now all the
sudden you're trying to do both these
things you're trying to hire a complete
staff interview those guys I don't I
believe in interviewing in person you
know and getting a good feel for your
coaches so there was a lot going on we
managed that the best that we could and
use the time when it was Alabama time
for Alabama's in it at night at the bowl
games or or in Tuscaloosa use that for
Florida Atlantic time and try to try to
do the best that we could and then
really after this last game you know
going through it and we had a month to
prepare and a month to do all this and
sitting there going wait we basically
have a little more than a week you know
and you still have you still haven't
finished half your staff down here
you've got mid-year recruits you know
that that start school coming up here in
about a week so there's a lot to do and
I just kind of reflected you know after
the game and watching the game I'm on
film and then sitting down with coach
and just think oh god I want to be here
but I don't know
you know the quarterback played it
played probably statistically his worst
game of the year you know it was that my
fault you know as I look at it you know
they look at calling the game did I call
a great game you know so I don't know
those answers but it was very hard as i
sat there to say okay am i putting these
kids that have worked so hard to get to
40 no with one game up in them
best position to win I'm trying to but
in the Nisa will you know ask yourself
you know was there times that you're
sitting in a meeting and you're thinking
about the other job or you're thinking
about what you have to do you know
you've got a coach flying in that night
you know and you're in you're in
meetings with the staff you know
watching film and you know you're
worried about who's picking up the
airport you know what what questions
you're gonna ask him in your minds kind
of both places and I said you know you
probably was you know not does that mean
that that that impacted the game I don't
know that answer but I didn't want to
sit there and say all of a sudden we
don't play well on offense and lose a
national championship game and it'd be
my fault that I didn't have the players
in best position to win so it was very
difficult we wouldn't have been able to
do it if sharp wasn't there you know
this is this is a very unique situation
because Sark and I think almost exactly
alike
we just have we just kind of grew up
together so when the call plays what to
call during the game during practices
what they're doing the red zone you know
we can go in separate rooms we used to
joke on separate rooms you can tell us
okay come on with the five best place to
run on the four yard line and we'll come
back I'll probably the exact same place
which it's just a strange thing and so
could you have stayed being in heroin
and too late yes yeah coach I talked
about it you know this was this was a
mutual decision but this was a decision
that you know I I needed to do I didn't
want to really but I needed to and I
think this is a you know part of the you
know the doc cloth maturity of being
with saving and and thinking things
through versus just snap decisions which
I've kind of made a lot of snap
decisions in my life that's just my
personality versus really coach thing
seems through a lot slower and you know
it took the took tonight to take it over
came back in the morning revisit it and
just said that this is the best of
players you know or shelter figuring out
what you know compliance wise how much I
can do because I want to help in every
way that I can you know to twin this
last game you know and trying to figure
out we kind of switch roles you know
we're
I'm kind of Sark you know off the field
and then he he becomes me you know
running the meetings and calling the
game because you can't do you know rule
lives not like the NFL where you can
just have as many coaches as you want
you know only the only the main coaches
are allowed to coach the actual players
you know how this looks though on the
outside right I'm sure I'm sure it's
very strangely but we're not worried
about that
you know coach always says one of the
hundreds of things I learned from me
always says you are to do what is the
best for the players in every decision
that you make no matter what it is and
this was that situation it didn't matter
and we talked at length about this and
slept on it and talk about it again
yesterday morning and it wasn't about
what the media is gonna say mm-hm it was
not about that all as well what is the
best for these players that have worked
so hard to get at this point
I mean what there's only been a couple
40 no teams in the history of football
you know and we're one of them right now
and what with us in the best position to
win this last one and finish an
unbelievable run of three straight SEC
championships and two back-to-back
national championships it's just it's
been an awesome run and I wouldn't be
able to live with that I screwed it up
you know by not doing what was best for
they should you have just taken the
Florida Atlantic job when it was given
to you in retrospect and just not back
down begging and not going back to
Alabama I don't know that you know
because again I don't know you know did
we not play that well in that game
because of that I mean that's a really
good defense I know a lot of people
don't have a lot of respect for
Washington because it is the you know
it's not the SEC but that's a really
good defense and one that I mean you saw
last night
USC how explosive how great they're on
offense you know and I think USC maybe
had 24 28 points or whatever it was
against Washington that was most all
your own you know they don't give up a
lot of explosive plays they play really
really hard on defense that they're
coached extremely well and so
I knew no matter what I didn't think
that was going to be a really high
scoring game because no one had done it
against him because they're really well
coached with a lot of really good
players I think those DBS are really
underrated I think that's that's one of
the best secondaries in the country at
Washington and and they're hard to
create explosive blazing hams and then
as the game was going you want to win
the game so I got extremely conservative
in the game in the second half on
purpose because I felt in that game the
way our defense was playing the way the
punter was putting the ball there was
one way to lose the game turnovers and
Washington was the number one turnover
team in the country coming in so said
all week to our players again and again
and again if you don't turn the ball
over we will win this game no matter
what and and our guys did that you know
they didn't turn them all over where you
like the game in Rome where you gonna
watch the national title game we're
still figuring that out you know like I
said we're still trying to figure out
you know what are the compliance rules
on this you know can I be in the press
box as a potential you know like star
like star pose for me and you know so
we're still we're still figuring it out
but we're gonna do everything we can to
make sure that that we win this thing
and finish what we started what's Coach
Saban one pardon what's what's Coach
Saban want with you for the national
title games he wants you helping in the
boers I feel that way yeah I mean that's
not how he left was you know we were
gonna you know find out what we can do
you know compliance wise you know what
are the exact rules ah this is a unique
situation and like I said not like it's
it's not like then I thought where you
can just add coaches you know when you
when you when you activate one like we
activated Sark for this game then no one
no matter what I can't coach the players
but we're trying to figure out can I do
what what started this whole year for me
can I be there that way for him well
good luck with whatever happens next
week and thanks for joining us good luck
at Florida Atlantic League all right
it's Lane Kiffin the Dan Patrick show we
day mornings on audience
[Music]